If my results for my cheek swab came back saying my cancer is
a meadow acid-based, does that mean I should never eat red meat again?
So we never say that your cancer is a meadow acid-based.
We might say that we think red meat can drive your cancer.
So if we think that red meat could be a driver of your cancer,
we recommend that you don't eat red meat.
Does it mean you could never eat red meat again?
No, that does not mean that.
So my personally, I believe when I tested myself,
I felt like my mind was driven by meat.
So I laid off of meat for some for fish for a long time.
But now I'm eating green meat again and I'm not having any fishers.
Is that the wisest thing to do?
Well, I don't know.
I'm praying about it and doing what I think is best.
So.